ARIA allows us to add extra semantics
into our HTML via attributes.
Essentially, it allows us to
modify the accessibility tree
without changing anything else about
the page presentation or behavior.
By default, it won't affect styling nor
will it affect interactive behavior.
The only thing it changes is how
the page appears to assistive
technology users.
We've already taken a look at how we can
use ARIA to change an element's role,
state and properties.
And how we can use ARIA to fine tune
the accessible name for an element.
Next stop, we're going to learn a little
more about how ARIA's semantics
interact with native HTML semantics.
We're also going to look at some special
ARIA attributes which allow us to
define some more nuanced
relationships between elements
than what we can express in the DOM.
And we're going to lie about how and
why we can choose to hide or
show information exclusively for
assistive technology users.